let's bring in Sarah Sanders Fox News
contributor former White House press
secretary Sarah welcome back thank you
great to be with you guys this morning
so the president laid out a framework on
Thursday and he said this will you need
to do to get through phase one two and
three and then a little bit later on he
tweeted out support for those protesting
do you believe you could do both lay out
a framework and support protesters use
the term liberate look there's nobody
who wants to reopen the government more
than president Trump he wants to see
people getting back to work he's a
businessman at heart and he wants
businesses in this country to be able to
open to be able to thrive at the same
time he has maintained social distancing
guidelines and I think people need to
take those seriously I think at the end
of the day millions of Americans are
frankly frustrated they're watching
liberal politicians like Nancy Pelosi go
on TV and and on social media parading
around flashing their $13 a pint ice
cream in their faces when they don't
have 13 dollars to feed their families
there's no doubt that they're frustrated
as a lot of these people that depend on
small businesses are angry that they're
not opening back up that their federal
government is delaying more funding that
we're seeing that from Pelosi and the
Democrats just over the last couple
weeks and as we saw Kevin McCarthy
talking about earlier people are getting
angry they're getting upset and they
want people out of touch politicians
like Nancy Pelosi to start paying
attention to the real needs that they
have and helping them step up and meet
those at the end of the day Congress
gets paid whether they show up to work
or not and they don't understand
sometimes that people that have to show
up in order to get a paycheck and can't
or frustrated some of these protesters
are right are angry the ones that are
showing up for these protests because
they're they don't want to stay at home
they want to be able to go outside and
do things as long as we're there with
the family and they're following the
rules so we saw all these protests over
the weekend we're gonna see ten across
the country today and some of them are
holding up signs area that say like in
the end the virus not the
me read one that said every day that
goes by you're hurting our state and
another guy says it's not worth
he said the shutdown and economic costs
not worth the few lives that it's going
that it will save so Nancy Pelosi was
asked about it and this is what she says
can you understand why they're doing
that
no really not really because what we
have to do is is is shelter in place
that is really the answer testing
tracing treatment shelter in place and I
do think that it's unfortunate but you
know people will do what they do but the
fact is we're all impatient we've all
want out but what they're doing is
really unfortunate Sarah what's your
reaction frankly I think what's
unfortunate is that an out-of-touch
multi-millionaire like Nancy Pelosi is
holding up the funding that would help
these people not just save lives but
save livelihoods this has been an
intense focus of the president is
protecting both parts of the American
Way of life both protecting individual
health and life of Americans across the
country as well as making sure we're
protecting their livelihoods and Nancy
Pelosi you can see that she frankly just
doesn't understand the frustration of
people who need their jobs or need
funding through the small business
package and legislation in order to get
their paychecks and keep things moving
she just frankly I think showed exactly
why she is so out of touch and I think
that's the most unfortunate thing about
it is that she's one of the people
making decisions for everybody else in
this country but she doesn't understand
the pain and the hurt and the suffering
that these people are going through
because she's not having to suffer or
experience any of that herself because
she has that cushion and that financial
security that most Americans don't have
you know Sarah I think the average
American watching this right now they're
worried about their health they're
worried about their wealth they wonder
this ends and when they see people who
are playing politics with this during a
time of a global pandemic whether it's a
Republican or a Democrat I've seen it
played on both sides of the aisle the
person at home just goes can't we get
this solved first because it's just it
just seems tone-deaf absolutely and I
don't think that there's probably
anything more disheartening than seeing
Washington being completely
dysfunctional at a time when we need it
to come together more than ever to help
the people of this country I think one
of the great things that has taken place
over the last several weeks as we've
seen the heart of America we've seen
people step up and help their neighbors
we've seen so many signs of people
showing compassion and love in a way
that we don't get to always appreciate
that we don't slow down to take I think
Washington needs to pay attention to
some of that compassion and some of that
love that everyday Americans are
constantly showing and try to reflect
some of that and move quickly to get
things done and make sure that people
have the resources and the things that
they need to continue and to carry on
with their way of life this is America
we still continue to be the greatest
country on the face of the planet let's
act like it let's get things done let's
make sure we're taking good care of
people I think the president has been a
strong leader on that front and we need
a rally around him we need to rally
around our governor's our doctors our
nurses and not politicize this fight but
really focus on the solutions instead of
the attacks right Sarah no matter what
they agree on on Wednesday or Thursday
it could have been done a week to ten
days ago there's really no excuse and
there's only one person who delayed it
and she's got really nice refrigerators
that's all I can say
Sarah Huckabee Sanders thanks so much
thank you thanks for having me on